are the chances that the two of you will
you know work together in like a comic
book movie Summer Time 83 chance I feel
like 17 is a no why that 17 is a no yeah
what's up with that no that's 17 yeah
well I don't know like if Hemsworth says
yes then but there's not that big of a
chance of that right yeah you can't you
can't afford him but you can't afford me
it won't kill anyone who gets in our way
no not kill anyone kill a few people
kill no people kill one guy one stupid
guy who no one loves now you're just
making it sad
[Music]
[Applause]
poor hello I'm good um now I'm just
gonna jump in right there and be really
honest with you three goals tend to suck
okay what does three cools oh yeah I
know yeah so what was your driving force
what was your North Star what was the
thing that made you all go you know
alphabetical it's gonna be awesome
instead because it's got this so what's
it this well I think it was really about
you know changing it's him I think it
was about you know I focused on telling
rocket story is the center of everything
and that was what we needed to do but we
also needed to finish each of the
characters stories with dignity and that
this was going to be the you know
allowing ourselves to make this the
final iteration of this group of the
Guardians makes it a truly three-act
story and that's something where we're
trying to set up some other movie Down
the Line so I think it was just taking
those that made it bold and made it
different and that was exciting but I do
have to say we started this journey in
Singapore like that was the very first
step of the press junket ever on a
Guardians movie was going to Singapore
this is our last interview on The Press
junket right now so I started in
Singapore and now I'm ending with
Singapore and that means Singapore is
special oh my God I love that uh no
Chris 10 years three Guardians of the
Galaxy movies what would you say is your
biggest takeaway from this entire
experience oh man uh there's so many
there's so much to take away it's hard
to pinpoint what would be the biggest
takeaway for me getting to work with
James and getting to work with a
filmmaker a tour like James was really
what separates this project from the
rest I'm really grateful that he picked
me to come along on this journey with
him it's been incredible I've made an
amazing amazing friend a lifelong friend
and I've been and I've learned so much
from working with them on how to be a
better actor how to be a better
Storyteller and and seeing firsthand by
watching him do it what it takes to be
an incredible filmmaker and it takes
dedication
commitment preparation
imagination and a willingness to get the
work done and to let your entire life be
dedicated to this work I mean he's he
said it himself about 60 or 70 percent
of his brain has been over the past 10
years focused just on these characters
just on this this family that he's
created and so the major takeaway is
you'd be really lucky if you get someone
like James to be uh Your Leader now
you're being so nice to me on the last
interview
now actually there's something nice
about you now I love that you mentioned
family because you guys are a Duo that
people love um I know James you
reiterated that this is like your final
Guardians of the Galaxy movie but you
know Chris will love you as a superhero
we love what you do at Star Lord so what
are the chances that the two of you will
you know work together in like a comic
book movie somewhere down the road 83
chance 83 chance
pretty good right yeah there's a good
listen we like we love working together
so I think if we can find something for
both of us that's the right project
we'll definitely do it you know I mean I
think it would be just it would be
really fun you know just for an excuse
to hang out with Chris for 90 days and
make jokes you know that's yeah that's
worth the price of admission right there
I feel like 17 is a no why that 17 is a
no yeah what's up with that no that's 17
yeah well I don't know like if Hemsworth
says yes then but there's not that big
of a chance right yeah you can't you
can't afford him but you can't afford me
no he just says no to more projects yeah
now
um
yeah no that listen you know sometimes
things don't go as planned sometimes you
can't you know listen like for instance
let's say we start working on a on a
project for a movie that we want to do
together and we write you know this to
start writing the scripts right working
out the story and it doesn't come
together it just doesn't work then we're
not going to make it I don't want to
make movies and Chris doesn't want to
make movies that aren't really going to
be something that we're giving something
to people that's excellent and we care
about the quality of things we're
neither one of us are the type to just
you know do things for money at all and
so it would have to be the right thing
things got to come together there's a
part of it that's me part of it that's
him and there's part of it that's just
God you know making sure that that's the
way things are going to go yeah
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]